pues nos piden factorizar de cuadrada
más ocho temas 15 ya antes quiero ver
qué es lo que pasa cuando nosotros
multiplicamos dos binomios de la forma
temas a por temas b y es que es justo de
esta manera como voy a querer factorizar
a este trinomio de la forma que más
aporte más b y bueno que no sean de
multiplicar temas aporte más bien pues
de este deporte me quedaría t cuadrado
después sería t por ver sería vete y
después sería aporte lo cual me daría a
t y después al último sería a por b y
bueno si te das cuenta aquí abajo
podemos factorizar una t tenemos de
cuadrada más vete masa te vas a ver 20
más a te podemos actualizar de que una t
y que me quedaría de cuadrada más a más
ve todo esto en paréntesis que
multiplica t t por aesa tt por beige
vettel más ave y bueno esto es justo lo
que yo quiero ver aquí en este vídeo si
te das cuenta lo que voy a buscar es que
aquí de cuadrada t en un 1
aquí te cuadrada tiene un 1 por lo tanto
vamos bien y después nos podemos fijar
en quién
el número que está al lado de la t este
número que es 8 tiene que ser a más b
tiene que ser la suma de los dos números
y el término libre el término que no
tienen nada que ver con temp es decir el
15 que tengo aquí tiene que ser el
producto de estos dos números y es más
yo podemos ver hasta en un caso mucho
más general que te hace en lugar de té
le ponemos x como siempre lo manejan si
nosotros tenemos alguna forma no sé x
cuadrada vamos a ponerlo aquí x cuadrada
más bx más 0 y el coeficiente que está
lado de la equis cuadrada es 1 entonces
buscaríamos dos números que sumados me
den b y que multiplicados me den c esto
de manera general aquí sumados me tienen
que dar 8 y multiplicados me tienen que
dar 15 y que son esos números bueno 15
se puede factorizar en 15 y 1 en 5 y 3
espera creo que sí fui 3 me parece una
buena opción 53 es 8 y 5 por 3 15 fíjate
bien lo voy a poner aquí si yo tengo 5 y
33 por 5 es 15 y 35 es 8 perfecto
entonces parece ser que ya encontré
mis términos que estoy buscando mis
números que estoy buscando entonces
ahora me voy a ir de regreso si es
cierto esto que acabo de decir entonces
esto se puede ver de la siguiente manera
lo voy a escribir así voy a ponerte
cuadrada después tengo vete pero en este
caso va a ser uno de los dos numeritos
que acaba de encontrar entonces voy a
suponer que es 3 entonces me queda t
cuadrada y ahora es aquí donde me voy a
fijar en los números que acabo de
encontrar 3 y 5 3 y 5 meses humano 7 por
lo tanto me va a quedar más tres veces
este más tres veces este más cinco veces
este para que me den 8 t fíjate que lo
que estoy haciendo es irme de atrás
hacia adelante
ahora voy de abajo hacia arriba tengo t
cuadrada más tres temas cinco temas 15 y
bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer es
factorizar por agrupación me voy a fijar
en los primeros dos términos y no voy a
fijar también en mis segundos dos
términos para factorizar esta expresión
y t cuadrada más 3 t es lo mismo que voy
a factorizar una t es lo más que se
puede reducir me va a quedar t que
multiplica a temas 3 y después de 5
entre más 15 me queda que me impactó
55 que multiplica a su vez ante 35 x 35
t y 5 por 3 es 15 entonces hasta aquí
vamos bien a continuación lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que aquí tenemos
temas tres temas 3 multiplicando tanto
ate como a 5 por lo tanto lo voy a sacar
como si fuera un factor común y entonces
me va a quedar temas 3 que multiplica a
temas 5 déjame poner un más que no
parezca tanto t un más un poco más
estructurado y me queda temas 5 y date
cuenta que temas 3 porte este por 33 y
temas 3 por si es 5 por temas 3 y qué
crees ya encontré la factorización de t
cuadrada más ocho temas 15 que esté más
3 por tema 5 y bueno no forzosamente se
tiene que hacer todo este procedimiento
hay veces que solamente fijándose en
esto que tenemos aquí arriba es decir
solamente buscando dos números que suma
a usted en 8 y multiplicado usted en 15
podemos encontrar el resultado